♪ ♪
>> Bret: FINALLY TONIGHT,
THERE ARE MOMENTS IN THE
TELEVISION NEWS BUSINESS THAT
TRANSCEND THE HEADLINES TO TOUCH
A SINGLE HEART PURE IN OUR OWN
SHANNON BREAM HEARD THE STORY OF
11-YEAR-OLD EMILIO PETRONE AND
SHARED IT ON TWITTER.
DYING FROM CANCER, AMELIO WHO
WANTED TO BE A MOVIE DIRECTOR,
ASK FOR ONE THING.
TO HEAR FROM HIS FAVORITE
HOLLYWOOD SUPERHEROES AND THEY
RESPONDED IN DROVES.
>> TO KNOW HE ONLY HAD A COUPLE
OF DAYS AND THIS IS ALL HE
WANTED AND THERE ARE ALWAYS
PEOPLE FROM HOLLYWOOD WHO DON'T
KNOW US, DON'T KNOW HIS FAMILY
STEP UP AND SAY THESE
PERSONALIZED ENCOURAGING VIDEOS
TO HIM, IT MAKES ME SEE THERE'S
SO MUCH GOOD IN THE WORLD AND
GOOD IN PEOPLE.
>> Bret: TODAY, EMILIO LOST
HIS BATTLE AGAINST CANCER, BUT
NOT BEFORE HE SAW SOME OF THOSE
VIDEOS.
SHANNON TELLS US HIS TWIN
BROTHER SEEN IN THIS VIDEO ARE
GRIEVING.
A TOUGH DAY, BUT VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THE OUTPOURING FROM HIS
SUPER FRIENDS.
LET ME TELL YOU TWO THINGS.
ONE, SHANNON BREAM IS A
FANTASTIC PERSON, SALT OF THE